Alright,
let's shift altogether.
Let's talk about the step.
You really know.
How about that.
Okay.
Biology,
evolutionary biology.
I thought this would be an interesting
place to start.
You just recently did a talk with
Richard Dawkins just in the last couple
of weeks.
Uh,
as I understand the video of it should
be up online somewhat soon.
It will be up within a couple of weeks.
Okay.
So hopefully people will be able to
actually watch this conversation.
I'm very quickly,
this event was put together by
Pangbourne philosophy.
There's been a little tumbled around
that and I know you just wanted to
quickly address what's going on there.
So pangbourne philosophy is obviously
imploded and that has left people
speculating about what happened and why
some of us like myself continue to
participate with Pangbourne.
I just very quickly for people that have
no idea,
they were putting together a lot of the
public events that included a,
well the one that you moderated with
Jordan Peterson and Sam Harris and
Vancouver.
Also the one that Douglas Murray
moderated,
which I think.
Was that in the UK or was that
Australia?
One in Dublin and one in London.
Yeah.
Um,
and then a series of other events like
the one that you did with Dawkins and
this this day of reflection that was
supposed to happen on November 17th that
we all pulled out of which now I think
you can take it from there.
Sure.
So,
um,
let me just say that I know that there
is a lot of speculation about what took
place,
why people pulled out of the New York
event,
why some of us like myself stayed in and
I was in at the point that it was
canceled a couple of days ago and I do
hope people will recognize that there
was a predicament for those of us like,
uh,
like myself and like Eric who were
looking at the,
uh,
the Pangbourne situation and trying to
figure out what to do,
which was at the point that Pangbourne
canceled the Auckland event.
Something new emerged.
So other events had been canceled,
but there had always been refunds for
people who had bought tickets.
At the point he canceled the Auckland
event.
There was a lack of refund money,
which called our attention to the fact
that something was off money that should
have been kept separately for that event
so that if it was canceled,
it could have all been refunded,
somehow wasn't,
which we didn't know.
And to be clear,
you guys,
and I think not just,
you guys hadn't been paid for some
previous things too,
so it wasn't just about the people that
were buying the tickets.
Just.
Oh,
it was an auckland,
it was Sydney.
Sydney is where speakers,
as far as I know,
that's where speakers didn't get paid
for the first time.
And I'm certainly one of the people who
didn't get paid and still haven't been.
Anyway.
Yeah.
And also as a sidebar,
that's.
So that is why I pulled out of the day
of reflection thing in New York.
I was supposed to host the whole day,
but then when I realized that people
hadn't been paid for previous things and
I had heard through the grapevine that
there was some shady stuff going on and
I just said,
you know what,
let me just
get involved in this mess.
And that's right,
which makes perfect sense.
Yeah.
So I think what I did also makes perfect
sense,
which is I looked at the situation and I
said,
well,
you've got people who haven't been
refunded their money for Auckland.
You've got speakers from Sydney who
haven't been paid and if the New York
event comes apart,
then it's going to compound that.
It's going to create a new ticket
holders who haven't been paid.
Um,
and so my thought was let's have an
event that gives people what they paid
for so that we don't make the damage
worse.
And I certainly didn't sign up for
anything new after the Auckland.
A event was canceled and there was a
failure to repay patrons.
But my thought was from the point of
view of a protecting the fan base from
whatever was going on a behind the
scenes at Pangbourne,
the better part of valor was to make the
event happen and be successful rather
than create another auckland situation.
So in any case that you know,
and I should also point out that up
until so Pangbourne gave us a,
a little bit of warning just a couple of
days before he canceled it,
he said he was about to cancel it and
Eric and I tried to save it.
In fact,
Eric who had pulled out of the event
quietly so as not to cripple it,
uh,
he and I got on the phone with Travis
and we tried to get travis to agree to
hold the event and to lead us rescue
that we offered to work for free and we
would have liked to have held the event
so that it wouldn't cause further harm
to people.
And I don't know why Travis refused,
but he did.
So anyway,
it got canceled and I,
uh,
I just,
I do want people to understand that it
was not that anybody was unaware that
something was going on.
The question was what's best for the fan
base,
the movement,
to the extent that there is a movement,
is it better to have another event
canceled and have more harm?
I didn't think so.
Yeah.
And I know this is all a little insider
baseball for people,
so I know you just wanted to get that
out.
So I'm glad that it is a few of us.
Also,
we had discussed possibly doing a free
thing and who knows,
maybe there will be something in the
future if people ended up getting
stiffed on ticket prices because
obviously we want people to get
something and if we can all figure it
out,
we will.
Okay.
So that being said,
you did do an event with Richard Dawkins
as we said the video should be up soon
enough.
Chicago,
what should we expect from this?
And uh,
I think on its face,
I think a lot of people would say,
wait a minute.
Well,
we've got Weinstein and Dawkins,
these guys should agree on everything,
shouldn't they?
Well,
this goes back to the question of what
happened to evolutionary biology 30
years ago and um,
darkens and I do agree on a tremendous
amount,
but the place at which we start
disagreeing I think is a,
the branching point where you have the
way evolutionary theory went 30 years
ago and the way it should have gone,
and you know,
that's not an indictment in and of
itself.
Fields take wrong turns all the time.
But what should happen is you should
detect that you're on the wrong path
because suddenly progress,
uh,
ceases and that didn't happen.
So,
so what actually happened 30 years ago
that got us that ironically a,
I would argue that the,
the last piece of progress that we all
really agree now there's been lots of
empirical work,
but the last piece of theoretical
progress actually involves a Dawkins'
selfish gene,
which essentially encapsulates a
synthesis that does lots of things,
including,
brings a proper theory of cultural
evolution online.
Which cultural evolution is a non issue
for almost all creatures.
But for birds and mammals,
it's a big deal.
And for human beings it is the big deal.
So to the extent that we did not have a
way of discussing cultural evolution
prior to the selfish gene doctrines,
introduction of the concept of memes
which have now been trivialized by,
you know,
people putting funny captions on
pictures,
but the concept of,
I think you could argue they've become
the most relevant way of communication
in a bizarre way.
Yes,
but they'd be,
they've become,
you know,
little tidbits become little bites and
the fact is almost everything about
human beings that is interesting and
special,
at least touches cultural evolution if
not is entirely housed there.
So in order to understand ourselves,
we have to get this cultural evolution
thing straight and documents set us,
I believe,
on the right path.
Chapter Eleven,
he introduces the word meme,
he introduces the concept,
he sets us in motion,
but he makes an error in that chapter.
No big deal.
We all make errors,
but it hasn't been corrected in 30
years.
And so,
so.
So what does that error?
The error is in a,
a misportrayed of the relationship
between culture and its evolutionary
units and genes and the way that they
evolve.
So what Dawkins says in that chapter is
that means the units of cultural
evolution exists in a new primeval soup,
right?
He says,
this is a new kind of evolution.
It begins at the point that culture
begins to happen and it is independent
of the genes that cannot be the case
cannot be the case because the only
reason that you are able to pick up
units of cultural evolution is because
you have a brain that your genes
created,
which is hospitable to those things,
which means that to the extent that
your,
a culture starts wasting the time and
the energy and the resources of your
genes,
the genes are in a perfect position to
shut it down.
Right?
So my point to dokkens on stage in
Chicago was that can't be right,
and if you make an adjustment to the
theory that you presented to the 1976,
if you adjust it correctly,
you discover that um,
many things that are paradoxical about
cultural evolution are no longer
paradoxical and many things about human
beings are suddenly tractable.
So can you give me an example of that?
I can give you the ultimate example,
I will accept that.
And so the ultimate example has to do
with a religion and things that function
like it.
So if you think about,
um,
you know,
this is the antithesis of some little
picture with a caption on it,
right?
You Imagine Catholicism,
for example,
Catholicism is a set of beliefs that has
profound implications on the way that
believers deploy their efforts,
their resources to things that they
elevate,
the things that they issue,
all of that.
So the question is why,
right?
So,
Docklands and I would agree there is no
supernatural explanation necessary to,
uh,
interpret what is taking place on earth
or anywhere else in the universe.
You don't need a supernatural
explanation.
Um,
if you were trying to explain phenomena.
So why is it that people who hold a
belief that supernatural forces are at
the heart of a human affairs?
Why are those people so successful?
Historically,
that's the question.
And Dawkins,
and I disagree with it,
I would disagree over it,
uh,
because a,
he has this view of what cultural
evolution is that it's independent of
genes.
I say it is actually much more flexible
than jeans,
but it is subordinate to the will of the
genes.
Um,
and he also does not subscribe.
Actually,
he came around a bit on this on stage I
thought,
um,
but he also does not subscribe to a,
uh,
a lineage level interpretation of
selection.
He is a traditional kin selectionist who
believes effectively that the
individual,
that the gene and the individual or the
places that we must interpret a
evolution.
And if you do that,
then lots of things are paradoxical,
hard to explain.
Maybe intractable.
If you accept that lineages evolve,
um,
that adaptation can apply to the
lineage.
Then you can begin to understand
phenomena like a religious traditions as
adaptive properties of a population.
And uh,
there is tremendous progress to be made.
So what happened on stage with Dawkins
was at dinner prior to the event,
we more or less agreed that I would lead
the discussion because I had a sense of
where we disagreed and he would react to
it.
And I put together a list of points on
which I was certain that we agreed
points on,
which I was pretty sure we disagreed and
which I wasn't sure which way to call
it,
which we didn't get to.
But anyway,
I started out by pointing out the vast
agreement between the two of us and
asked them about each one and more or
less I had been right about where we
agreed.
And then I started going through the
list of places that we disagree.
And I thought it was a fascinating
conversation.
It was definitely a closer to the
conversation I hoped we would have won.
I feared we might have,
um,
there was a lot of progress.
Could you,
could you sense which way?
Not that this matters in the grand
scheme of things,
but at some level it does.
Which way the audience was going.
Not that it,
not that it is about who gets more
cheers or anything.
But what I do find fascinating about
these things.
And although I didn't attend any of the
live events with Sam and Jordan,
um,
you know,
I've watched some of them and just sort
of noting a little bit of crowd applause
and jeers and pauses and things I think
gives you some extra taste that may be
for you guys on stage.
You can't quite quantify.
Well,
I mean,
first of all,
I'm a believer in that and it was one of
the most of them
important tools that I used to use in
the classroom,
you know,
figuring out what people heard,
how it landed,
what they don't yet have.
So anyway,
I'm very cognizant of what people are
hearing and I was listening carefully to
the audience and um,
you know,
the thing was set in motion,
as another new atheist event.
And so in some sense I was,
I was battling uphill because my basic
point was new atheism is,
is a Culdesac,
it's,
it's a problem in and of itself.
Um,
it's a problem because at the end,
at the end of it,
there isn't enough.
Is that like the most simplistic way
that I could present it?
No.
I mean,
let me just put it in stark terms.
Atheism is defensible,
but new atheism is wrong and new atheism
is wrong because it portrays religious
belief as a
of mind rather than an adaptation,
non literal adaptation and so in a room
full of people who,
you know,
Dawkins is a very famous person because
people presumably showed up to hear a
Dawkins.
Almost all of those people have at least
deep sympathies with the ideas of new
atheism and so somebody setting out to
say actually new atheism is an incorrect
instantiation of atheism because it is
effectively ideological and and accuses
people who have religious faith of being
mentally defective and in fact darkens
and I tangled over this.
You know,
I said,
look,
you're,
you've called religion a mind virus.
That's an incorrect interpretation.
And at first he said,
well,
I don't really mean anything deep by
virus.
He said it's,
you know,
you could argue that every gene in the
genome is like a virus.
Right?
And I said,
well,
but what people hear when you say that
is that,
that they're mentally ill for believing
this.
And he said,
well,
they are mentally ill,
right?
And so you know,
you could see the division in his own
thinking,
right?
Because at that point he's then saying
both things at the same time,
Sandy's saying both things and I,
you know,
I understand his position about you
could interpret each gene has
independent,
you know,
I could defend that position too,
but in order for there to be an
honorable atheism,
we have to own up to what all that
religious belief was about.
And then I mean,
and this is the place that I get into an
easier pickle,
but a pickle with Peterson as well is
the question of if we acknowledge that
religious belief is adaptive,
then all of the things that are true of
adaptive phenomena kick in and the most
important one is that adaptive phenomena
are not timeless.
They are adaptive relative to a
historical time and place.
And it may be a very long standing time
and place.
But the point is there is nothing.
It is purely magical thinking to imagine
that religious traditions that are
thousands of years old are the core of
the toolkit for moving forward.
Our existence in 2018 is so novel that
if there's one thing we can be sure of,
it's that are adaptive nature is a poor
match for it.
So then can anything be truly timeless?
Is that the right question?
Well,
yeah,
but the way you do it is this,
the longer standing,
some truth of some kind is the closer it
gets to being timeless.
In other words,
if we look at things that are um,
very evolutionarily longstanding,
well those things have persisted through
environments that were very different
from each other.
So what that means is that thread still
functions irrespective to an extent of
the context.
The longer it lasts,
the more likely it is to speak to truths
that continue to be relevant,
but the,
the bitter pill for modern people with
respect to understanding the degree to
which evolution is the key to seeing
ourselves properly is that we live in
circumstances that are more novel than
almost any creature has ever faced.
Now,
you know a creature can,
you know,
fish and flop into a boat and it's
suddenly a novel circumstances and it's
dead within minutes,
right?
Don't tell that to the dinosaurs and the
media was coming.
Well,
there you go.
That was so novel that you know,
I mean dinosaurs didn't survive that one
group,
the birds,
you're still with us and they're doing
great,
but we are creatures living in
circumstances that are not only novel at
an unprecedented level but are changing
so rapidly that even to the extent that
we can figure out what to do,
the world changes out from under us.
We have to stop that,
right?
That is going to kill us.
That if you want to know what the
greatest existential threat to humanity
is,
it is the rate of change that we have
set in motion,
which makes it impossible for us to
adapt fast enough to it.
It has to be slowed down to a point that
we can catch up.
Is that impossible though,
because we already have that power
because I'm with you on this.
Just from my limited knowledge of this,
just from what I do,
you know,
from doing these shows and that people
can watch more,
you know,
the amount of information that you can
intake on a given day,
the amount of things that you can share,
you can speed things up and listened to
them two times as fast.
You can clip everything and that we can
take all of this information.
Things can be live streamed like all of
this bang,
Bang,
Bang.
It's happening faster.
We're learning more.
We know there's a great thirst for this.
Um,
but can it be slowed down?
I mean,
what,
what force could slow down progress
really wisdom.
Um,
and that that's the,
that's the problem is that we are
children in this landscape and children
grow up,
right?
I mean,
the key to raising children properly is
to,
is to back off the things that protect
them enough that they actually get
burned without being burned so severely
that they're crippled.
In other words,
you have to experience the places that
your notions are naive in order to
become less night.
We are now in a situation in which we
are behaving in a childlike fashion in,
you know,
in a very,
in a foundry or something like that.
Right?
We're like children running around in
the foundry.
There's molten metal that we need to,
you know,
figure out how to recognize it,
how not to touch her were just pressing
every button.
Going buttons are cool.
There's power.
We've got to stop doing that.
I don't think,
you know,
if I'm to be candid about it,
I don't think we are in an unrecoverable
situation.
I can see the path forward and it's all
still plausible as far as I know,
but I'm worried that we won't get there
and the reason we won't get there is
that there are lots of things that have
been true that just aren't true anymore.
In other words,
the people who are in love with a
limitless market in which you can do
anything that you can manage and it's
all cool.
And then at the point we find out that
it isn't cool.
We might have to take some action,
but in the meantime,
you know,
you're,
you're free to explore.
I'm very sympathetic to this view as
well.
I would be sympathetic to this view if I
didn't recognize that there was a
problem in which,
for example,
if you look at the way our economic
system is hooked up to our political
system,
there's a problem where anytime you set
a new force in motion in the market,
if that force pays a at a high rate in
the short term,
but it costs at a high rate in the
longterm,
by the time you get around to
discovering the costs in the long term,
it has found its way into the political
system so that it cannot be reversed.
You can't have a system in which you
can't reverse things.
So this,
the simplest way to frame this would be
some sort of crony capitalism kind of
thing,
right?
Well,
you know,
we're not,
we're not truly free market because
we've politicized a competition
basically.
Well,
you know,
I try to look at everything through an
evolutionary lens and to me,
politics and economics are just one more
landscape.
And they're interesting because it's
humans and humans are,
um,
especially capable in this regard.
But the,
um,
the natural tendency for a creature that
has found its way into a niche is to
protect its access to that niche.
And the way creatures do that is they
freeze other creatures out.
So there is this natural pattern,
and I mean I can't not see it now that
I,
now that I've understood that it exists.
There's this natural pattern where the
upstarts who succeed,
the stories that we know we don't know
about the upstarts that failed mostly,
but you have startups that succeed end
up tremendously powerful.
And then they go through this process in
which they become hostile to upstart
newness and they become hostile to
upstart and us for the most natural of
reasons which is that their wellbeing
depends on shutting down the process
through which they became successful.
So this could be like facebook buying
all of their competitors and things of
that nature.
It's the,
let's put it this way,
there are obvious versions and then
there are innumerable versions that are
cryptic and we,
we're never going to understand the
whole landscape of ways in which those
who have reached this level of power
that you and I will only dream about,
that they will then shut down the access
to others.
It's like there's a,
I don't even want to call it a
conspiracy because it doesn't have to
have any consciousness to it at all,
but there is a tendency for,
um,
for those who have succeeded to shut
down the,
the mechanisms through which they
succeed.
I mean,
you can see this with a people
frequently remarking on the fact that
immigrants are often not that wildly
enthusiastic about immigration.
Why is that?
For obvious reasons.
You know,
you're talking about do people who've
just entered at the bottom of the
economic ladder want more competition?
Well,
they're actually a.
there's a tension between what people
should want that you shouldn't imagine
that there's some immigrant ness that
necessarily has you favorable to anybody
else who has that label.
Does this also sort of explain a little
bit of what's happening in the tech
world right now in terms of it seems
that these companies,
twitter,
facebook,
youtube,
are potentially at least using
algorithms against their own audience,
a shadow banning people.
I mean that they are basically now
turning against their own people because
of their whatever they perceive to be
their own protection or longterm health.
Even though I would probably argue in
most cases,
that's not really what's going to
happen.
Oh,
without question.
This is what's going on and let's put it
this way.
If you're at the top,
if you're in that strata,
you have a lot to lose through anything
you can't predict,
and so there is a way in which we expect
the upstart who got there through some
sort of radical transformation to be
favorable throughout a radical
transformation.
But the way we should understand it is
that once you've gotten there,
radical transformation becomes
threatening and you start to
conservatizing evolutionary force and
you know,
we can look at what twitter is playing
with these days with a potentially
eliminating like some follower counts.
You know,
at a breathtaking act of paternalism,
you know,
at best and are doing it for us,
for us,
right?
Because we shouldn't be so concerned
about who's paying attention.
But really the truth is,
as much as we all recognize that there's
a problem with,
you know,
tweeting to get trivial likes,
on the other hand,
understanding what your audience hears,
what they find favorable,
what doesn't ring true to them is the
way you learn,
it's the way you steer.
And so effectively twitter is playing
with blinding us so that we can say
whatever we want into the void,
but we have no idea how it,
there's no ping back to you basically.
And so,
you know,
I mean,
I don't need to tell you,
you're a comic,
you're standing in front of the room and
you get a
lot better when they laugh.
It's better,
it's better when they laugh.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
Um,
what should we be thinking,
you know what,
before I get to that.
So as you know,
I was just in a,
in Europe and I did a bunch of the
Scandinavian and Nordic countries and
uh,
Sweden was a particularly interesting
case because I know that our fifth most
viewed country for this show is Sweden,
which is sort of fascinating considering
how tiny Sweden is.
Uh,
so I,
I sort of circled that we did two shows
in Sweden.
I kind of circled them on the calendar
because I was like,
something's going on in Sweden.
I want to figure out what it is now.
I thought if you would've asked me
before I did the show that first night,
I thought it was gonna have a lot to do
with immigration.
What I realized,
although there were a lot of questions
about immigration at the end,
it had much more to do with gender and
what is happening to their highly
egalitarian society that have done most
of the things related to gender and true
equality correctly for many,
many years.
And all of our friends on the left
always point to Sweden and Norway and
Finland.
These countries that I was just as the
examples of their perfect societies and
they're really struggling with certain
things that you know,
that the government's forcing them to
have genderless kindergartens and that
the,
the emasculation of men and the removal
of the father and that they have
supposedly Europe's first feminist
government and all of these things.
So I thought as long as I have you here
and since gender seems to be such an
endlessly a provocative and also
misunderstood topic,
um,
what should we do on gender right now?
Yeah.
Um,
well beyond you going to Sweden and
figuring out what's going on there.
Something.
Well,
what struck me as is that they've done
everything right in effect in terms of
egalitarianism and they've done it for,
for decades now.
They've done it right.
And when they got to the end,
which is now,
and they got to the current day,
they realized that despite all of this
equality,
men and women are still different.
That women still care more about people
and men still care more about things.
So even though they've been given the
exact same opportunity,
women are still becoming nurses and men
are still becoming engineers and it's
like the social justice warriors or
whatever you want to call that crew,
they still don't like the results of
true equality.
So I think that's why Sweden's in such a
weird place,
the average person's like,
what?
We've done it right,
we did it right.
Everyone's equal.
You can do whatever we want,
but then the result isn't being allowed
to be accepted.
Does that,
does that make some sense?
Oh,
it makes perfect sense.
In fact,
right?
I think the,
uh,
the naive left finds the failure of its
hypothesis absolutely galling.
And so they're effectively trying to
erase that failure by hard coding the
solution into government.
So I think that's exactly what's
happening in Sweden right now.
And it's tragic.
And with respect to sex and gender,
it is so needless,
right?
The fact is the truth of sex and gender
is,
there are parts of it we don't fully
understand yet,
but in general,
actually we do.
We pretty much understand how we got
here.
And the truth is,
it is asymmetrical.
It is a complimentary.
The truth of male and female is a
complimentary truth.
It may be largely irrelevant in the
present.
In other words,
technology has eliminated most of the
basis on which the division of labor
between men and women initially evolved.
So I think we have actually an
opportunity here to become,
to behave in an enlightened fashion that
the the easiest place to solve this
problem,
insects and gender,
what we should do is pretty clear and it
is not hard to ground and evolutionary
theory because unlike other places like
a race,
for example,
we do know what to think with respect to
sex and gender and the.
The basic outline is this.
Men and women are different for
historical reasons.
The basis for that difference and the
utility of that difference has largely
been neutralized by the modern world.
We don't need to retain those
distinctions,
but some of those distinctions are built
in at a deeper level than others.
So meaning you could potentially be a
stay at home dad and that could be
perfectly fine,
but that probably for evolutionary
reasons is not going to be the thing
that usually happens,
right?
But here's your would be my point.
We can democratize access to almost
every with respect to sex and gender,
there are very few places where we
actually need to have some asymmetry in
access,
but probably,
you know,
the firefighter who comes into the
burning building through the roof to
pull you out when you're panicking and
you don't know what to do because you've
never been in a fire before.
Um,
on average,
that should probably be a guy.
They're just better built for it.
If there's a woman who is well enough
able to do it,
should you be picky about the
firefighter who plucks you out of the
burning building?
Absolutely not.
I mean,
I personally am thrilled to see it every
time it runs against the narrative that
we expect.
You know,
I,
uh,
I'm very fond of Stacey Brown,
the police chief at Evergreen,
who was driven out along with heather
and me.
I thought it was great that she was
female and that she was a,
an excellent cop.
So I'm,
I'm up for the narrative being broken
by,
uh,
by reality as often as possible,
but you democratize the access,
but you don't force people to do what
they otherwise would for one thing,
you wouldn't even want to force it
because for every job that you would,
you know,
force women into at some higher rate,
let's say engineering jobs because it
sounds like a good thing to do.
There are some awful job that men are
disproportionately represented in that
you would also have to force them into
to be fair.
So you democratize the access.
You recognize that the division of Labor
that we have,
that we have inherited is largely
outdated.
Um,
but you don't override people's a
choice,
you know,
if,
if women,
if you democratize access to engineering
perfectly and women go into it at equal
rates,
great.
If they don't,
that's cool too.
Um,
so in any case,
it's,
it's a question of allowing liberty to
decide where people go after you've done
away with unnecessary barrier.
Well,
it's so interesting because I think then
you hit it right on the head that,
well,
Sweden's now politicizing it.
They're making a point of making this
political because they will not accept
the science of what they've done
correctly.
And I think at that is what is what has
led this sort of average person there to
go this,
this is just not right.
So it's,
I don't know what the way out is and I
sense that most of the people there
didn't know what the way I was.
Well,
I mean,
the way out really is to recognize that
the,
the ire of the authoritarian left on
this point is actually indicative of the
whole problem.
In other words,
because sex and gender is more or less
clear,
the desire to erase it,
irrespective of the collateral damage is
an indicator of just how wrong this path
is.
So,
you know,
I find this all the time where people
have,
if you're not focused on biology and
you're focused on the world that you
find in your galled by,
uh,
by inequality,
then you think,
well,
let's just solve the inequality.
Which is hard code the solution,
but then you hard code the solution and
it says men and women of the same to the
extent that there's any difference in
what they choose to do,
that's the result of a either cryptic
barriers or internalized misogyny or
whatever,
and then the problem is you're now
interfering with my biology class.
You're now telling me that we that the
received wisdom is that men and women
are the same thing.
When I know damn well that can't be
right,
so you don't want to build a solution
that forces you to confront your
biologists,
physicists,
your statisticians,
right?
You want all of these stories to the
extent that they're true,
have to reconcile all true stories,
records to the extent that you've got a
naive notion over here and you want to
just write it in because it seems very
important to you and you're willing to
tolerate all of the cascading effects
elsewhere.
You don't belong in a position of power.
Unfortunately though,
a lot of those people are in a position
to power and I think we're seeing more
of them get into positions of power and
I think it's also now having a counter
effect in Europe,
which is why we're seeing the rise of
more far right parties because people
are just like,
screw this,
this is so wrong.
I'm going to take my chances over here.
People who inherently are not say far
right or certainly not racist,
are now playing with people that perhaps
they wouldn't have played with before
because they're so sick of this and I.
and I'm worried where that leads us.
Oh,
I think,
I think this is exact and I've,
I've heard you say this,
is that you were afraid that the,
the lunacy over on the authoritarian
left is actually going to,
you know,
it's collapsed.
It's going to leave people who otherwise
wouldn't play ball with the far right
over there,
but not because they're racist.
That's the key to this.
It's not that they'll suddenly become
wake up and be racist or hate women or
hate gays,
but it will be such a disgust of
reality.
And,
and,
and a rejection of what's provable that
they'll going to be like,
at least there's something over here.
I mean,
it's awful bargain,
but I think it is.
I think,
I just think it is.
I see this,
uh,
frequently where people,
you know,
because they detect that there's
something wrong with communism and
socialism are often driven,
right pretty far into the let's not
regulate anything camp and the answer is
actually have to regulate stuff just out
of a desire to continue as a species.
So,
you know,
I don't want to see people driven
because there's something wrong over
here.
I don't want people to be driven into,
into a reactionary position that is not
justified.
The thing on sex and gender though is
maybe this is the key question.
Every reasonable person who just simply
observes the world knows that men and
women are not the same thing.
They know that,
uh,
those differences have an implication
for the way we view all sorts of things
like mating and dating,
what careers we want to have,
how we view risk and all of these things
for historical reasons.
All reasonable people can infer that
from just their own observations of the
world.
You are now confronted with people who
insist that you not acknowledge what you
can see.
Those people are crazy,
right?
They're dangerously out of control.
They are dangerously out of control on
other topics where it's harder to know
what's true,
but you wouldn't want people who were so
naive as to argue that men and women are
effectively identical,
but for depression,
in charge of any policy,
you don't want them in charge of
economic policy,
in charge of,
uh,
you know,
a prisons,
anything.
Um,
so having seen just how far their
confusion goes,
can we all agree to shut them out of the
discussion about how power is to be
wilted and the rest of us can have a
discussion about what our values are,
what we think we know,
what we don't yet know,
and what its implications are.
That that's the place we should go.
That seems like an effective ending
here.
Unless you want to throw in one more.
Did we not hit something that's been
rattling around in your brain?
Actually,
he's a know I covered a lot of territory
here.
Yeah.
All right,
well it's always a pleasure sitting down
and India.
And you joined me last night for standup
in Bray California.
This will be up already,
but you're joining me tonight and
Oxnard,
I'm turning into a standup comic,
which is a biologist.
Worst nightmare.
No,
no,
it's a,
it's not quite the,
uh,
the thing where you're,
the lead singer of your favorite band
has laryngitis
data,
but it's about as close as I could hope
to go.
Yeah.
All right.
Well we're going to do this.
Will do.
Well,
we did it about a year ago after the
original line,
but we'll do this more than once a year
because you're,
you're right in the center of all the
things that I think are,
are right at the moment and for more on
Brett,
follow him on twitter as long as they
can track how many followers he has at
Bret Weinstein.